france espère un bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
c'est une légère augmentation de la
production de pétrole l'opep qui ouvre
petit à petit on va dire les vannes
après les avoir serré de manière très
forte
concrètement qu'est ce que cela veut
dire d'abord cela veut dire que les 23
pays membres de l'opep plus donc les 13
pays membres de l'opep plus j 10 pays
non opep ont réussi à dépasser l'échec
de leur réunion récente au tout début
juillet et ils l'ont fait relativement
rapidement puisqu'une quinzaine de jours
après ils ont annoncé hier un accord ce
d'un premier point positif
deuxième point ils y ont comme vous la
dédie en introduisant ce sujet décidé de
produire plus de pétrole
quatre cent mille barils par jour de
pétrole chaque mois entre le mois d'août
est la fin de l'année c'est très
important pour le marché pétrolier
mondial et pour l'économie mondiale
parce que nous sommes en 2021 avec une
forte croissance économique au niveau
mondial plus de 5% par an
vraisemblablement et quand vous avez une
forte croissance économique
le monde a besoin de plus de pétrole
pour pouvoir tourner à plein régime sur
le plan économique et industrielle et
donc c'est l'assurance pour les pays
importateurs et consommateurs de pétrole
c'est à dire est plus grande partie du
monde qu'il y aura plus de pétrole sur
le marché
un troisième élément clé c'est que les
émirats arabes unis qui avaient bloqué
la réunion au début juillet ont obtenu
satisfaction pas totalement mais ils ont
dû de pouvoir produire plus de pétrole
l'opep plus a fait une concession pour
éviter un nouveau blocage de la part de
ce pays qui est un important producteur
au sein de l'opep
et puis pour le front des prix les prix
du pétrole sont maintenant si on prend
le prix du pétrole brent de la mer du
nord entre 73 et 74 dollars par baril
c'est un prix qui est intéressant pour
les pays producteurs exportateurs
c'est un prix qui n'est pas trop élevé
pour les consommateurs
donc pour l'instant plutôt une bonne
nouvelle en terme de 10
auditer du pétrole et de prix pour
l'économie mondiale pour les semaines et
les mois qui viennent les enjeux et les
tensions diplomatiques entre justement
les pays producteurs de pétrole ont
changé après cette crise sanitaire
la crise sanitaire a été une rupture
importante en 2020 cela a fait fortement
chuter les prix du pétrole qui se sont
effondrés entre janvier et avril 2020 et
cela fait baisser la consommation
mondiale de pétrole l'an dernier en 2020
la consommation de pétrole a baissé
d'environ 9% alors qu'elle ne faisait
qu'augmenter au cours des dix années
précédentes
par contre en 2021 avec les programme
massif de vaccination
avec le recul de la pandémie même si
celle ci n'est pas morte loin de là on
pense évidemment aux variants ovarian
delta et cetera avec une forte reprise
économique chine etats unis union
européenne
l'ensemble du monde et bien la
consommation repart à la hausse les prix
ont fortement augmenté
rappelons qu'en avril 2020 le prix du
pétrole brent produit en mer du nord et
des tombes et 1,18 dollar par baril
aujourd'hui nous sommes entre 70 et 75
dollars par baril d'aucune très forte
remontée des prix et des pays
producteurs qui sont assez satisfait la
demande mondiale repart à la hausse les
prix sont suffisamment rémunérateurs
donc c'est une bonne situation pour ces
pays
après une année terrible 2020 pour
l'économie mondiale pour le secteur
pétrolier et pour les pays producteurs
exportateurs de pétrole comme les 23
pays de l'opac puce merci beaucoup
francis perrin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle qu'on est
directeur de recherche à l'iris et
spécialiste à des problématiques
énergétiques